café vous avez dû suivre les débats mars
la pétition 742 intitulé more violences
et abus liés à la chasse plus jamais ça
a donc été déposée le 10 septembre
dernier par vous même sur la plateforme
i pétition du sénat et elle a dépassé
les cent dix mille signatures avant même
qu'elle n'ait atteint le seuil des cent
mille signatures les commissions des
affaires économiques et des lois et je
salue madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques ont
décidé de créer une mission conjointe
ayant dépassé donc ce seuil des cent
mille signatures la conférence des
présidents sané saisi le 23 novembre
dernier en application du règlement du
sénat et elle a confirmé son renvoi en
commission et la création de notre
commission conjointe de contrôle en
conséquence et en application du
règlement du sénat la conférence des
présidents a également décidé de clore à
la signatures la pétition 742 mais aussi
quatre autres pétitions qui avait trait
aux questions de sécurité à la chasse et
qui avaient été déposées à la suite de
votre pétition pour la contester ou en
étendre le champ le 24 novembre les deux
commissions ont désigné les 19 membres
de la mission à la proportionnelle des
groupes politiques et mardi derniers
mardi le 30 novembre la mission a
désigné m'a désigné comme présidente et
nous avons désigné patrick chaize comme
rapporteur et nous avons arrêté notre
programme de travail
ce programme de travail est largement
définie par la pétition elle même et la
mission conjointe de contrôle traitera
de l'ensemble des points soulevés par la
pétition et je les rappelle les
conditions de délivrance et de
renouvellement du permis de chasser
notamment l'âge les épreuves où les
capacités médicales et psychologiques
les conditions de sécurité des chasses
notamment les zones de protection autour
des habitations l'interdiction de
l'alcool l'encadrement des battues
l'émission de l'ouest b et de la
gendarmerie nationales notamment la
réglementation relative à l'acquisition
et à la détention d'armes et des
munitions de chasse les sanctions qui
peuvent résulter d'éventuelles
infractions le partage des espaces
naturels dans le temps et en fonction
des différents usages la prise en charge
des victimes elle effectuera également
un premier bilan du volet sécurité à la
chasse de la loi du 21 juillet 2019
notamment sur la formation des chasseurs
la rétention et la suspension du permis
de chasse en cas d'accident grave est
par ailleurs une étude de législation
comparée à d'ores et déjà été lancé afin
de prendre en compte les meilleures
pratiques étrangères et d'actualiser
l'étude très complète qui avait été
réalisée en
2007 mission a bien sûr aussi vocation à
entendre toutes les parties prenantes
sans a priori et nous commençons donc
très logiquement aujourd'hui avec vous
mesdames qui avait été à l'origine de
cette pétition nous nous rendrons
également sur le terrain pour mieux
examiner les conditions dans lesquelles
sont conduites les battues sont formés
les chasseurs et sont réalisés les
contrôles nous irons aussi à la
rencontre des victimes
le travail est donc important et notre
mission va se donner le temps de
travailler son rapport est attendu à
l'été après les élections pour étudier
ce sujet en dehors de l'émotion et des
polémiques l'objectif de la mission est
donc de traiter de la sécurité à la
chasse dans tous ses aspects
mais il n'est pas d'entrer dans une
discussion pour ou anti chasse la chasse
est une activité légale et populaire qui
peut impliquer usage d'armes à feu elle
doit donc être soumises à des
réglementations et des impératifs de
sécurité particulier et proportionnée
dans l'intérêt même des chasseurs mais
bien évidemment aussi des non chasseurs
enfin avec notre rapporteur patrick
chaize je voudrais affirmer notre
détermination à travailler pour que
autant qu il est possible d accident de
chasse puisse être évitée à l'avenir
chaque victime est une victime de trop à
cet égard cette audition intervenant
quelques jours après l'anniversaire de
la mort dramatique de votre amie morgane
tin le 2 décembre 2020 je voudrais vous
faire part de nos sincères condoléances
et de tout le respect que nous inspire
votre démarche
mesdames mais maintenant je vais vous
laisser la parole en avant de remercier
aussi tous les collègues présents un
bonne participation aujourd'hui une
grande partie de la mission et je vais
vous laisser la parole pour une
vingtaine de minutes à poutrer et
ensuite notre rapporteur aura sûrement
des questions à vous poser ainsi que nos
collègues je remercie
finement
le 2 décembre 2020 en plein confinement
notre ami d'enfance et voisins morgan
keane a été abattu par un chasseur qui
l'aurait confondu avec un sanglier alors
qu'il coupait du bois dans son jardin
avec une tronçonneuse il était 16h45 la
nuit commençait à tomber et morgane
porter un casque antibruit orange plus
haut le lendemain le procureur du lot
affirmé que toutes les règles de
sécurité avaient été respectées ce que
willy schraen président de la fédération
nationale des chasseurs a répété le mois
dernier à propos du drame qui a coûté la
vie à joël viard qui était au volant de
sa voiture cette phrase nous a
interpellés on parle de morts on parle
de balle dans le cou sur une quatre
voies entre rennes et nantes
deux balles de gros calibre en plein
thorax dans son jardin et on nous parle
du respect des règles de sécurité parler
de règles de sécurité lorsqu'elles sont
meurtrières et elles permettent que les
conditions soient les gags légalement
réunies pour que de tels drames se
produisent c'est se rendre complice de
ces morts et les banaliser
voici un exemple de ce qu'on appelle
règles de sécurité aujourd'hui en france
en bordure de la n 12 dans les yvelines
un panneau de chasse en cours que sont
censés faire les automobilistes pour
être prudent
après la mort de morgane les lotois
autour de nous ne cessé de répéter ça
devait arriver il fallait s'y attendre
cette absence de surprise et les
réactions des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux nous ont sidéré aux quatre coins
de la france des voix s'élevaient chaque
jour de plus en plus nombreuses pour
dénoncer des comportements abusifs de
chasseurs très vite nous avons pris
conscience de l'importance et de
l'ampleur de ce problème qui dépasse l
échelle locale il nous était impossible
de continuer à ignorer la mise en danger
permanente des bureaux 7 jours sur 7
pendant six à dix mois de l'année nous
avons donc décidé de briser l'omerta est
de faire un état des lieux des abus liés
aux pratiques de chasse en collectant
des témoignages donc des ruraux nous
leur avons permis de s'exprimer en
reliant leurs témoignages sur les
plateformes instagram facebook et
twitter dont l'audience se comptent
aujourd'hui
en plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes c'est comme cela qu'est né le
collectif un jour un chasseur le 7
décembre dernier ce collectif a permis
la libération massive de la parole des
victimes de la chasse nous avons donc
synthétiser les aspirations des ruraux
et proposer des réformes pour garantir
la sécurité de tous les habitants et
usagers des campagnes qui demande
simplement de ne pas risquer de se faire
tirer dessus chez eux et sur les chemins
où il aime se promener
depuis maintenant un an nous recevons
chaque jour une vingtaine de témoignages
faisant état entre autres deux
sentiments d'insécurité et de peur
d'aller se promener en raison de battu
non signalée d'attac de chiens de chasse
de tir proches dangereux un contrôle et
de mise en danger d'autrui d'injures de
menaces des insultes de conflits d'usagé
d'intrusion sur des propriétés privées
de blessures ou de mort d'animaux
domestiques de tirs dans des maisons des
chambres d'enfants des salons des
jardins des trains et des voitures en
circulation
des plaintes refusé en gendarmerie ou
classer sans suite même lorsque le
chasseur responsable du tir dangereux a
été identifiée
de blessures physiques et de tir mortel
voici maintenant l'express l'extrait
d'un tableau recensant les 52 accidents
suffisamment sérieux pour être relayée
par la presse concernant les non
chasseurs qui ont eu lieu entre le 31
juillet et le 29 novembre 2021 sur cette
période de quatre mois un accident a été
médiatisé tous les deux trente jours
parmi lesquels un mort nos chasseurs
onze blessés douze animaux domestiques
blessé ou tué 14 tirent sur des maisons
véhicules neufs non respect de la
propriété privée et menaces 5 entraves à
la circulation et mise en danger dans
l'espace public trois points importants
doivent être précisées cette liste ne
concerne que les non chasseurs il a eu
beaucoup plus de chasseurs tués et
blessés sur la même période cette
statistique n'est que la partie émergée
de l'iceberg car comme nous l'avons dit
nous recevons chaque jour une vingtaine
de témoignages qui rapporte des faits
similaires et qui ne sont pas médiatisés
enfin je recensement qui est minime elle
est bien la preuve que l'insécurité des
ruraux et des usagers des campagnes réel
généralisée et quotidienne et que des
mesures doivent être mises en place de
toute urgence
il est grand temps d'écouter les besoins
les demandes des ruraux ainsi que d'un
grand nombre d'élus locaux et de combler
un vide législatif et institutionnel au
niveau national afin d'empêcher que de
nouveaux drames se produisent alors
qu'ils auraient pu être évités c'est
pourquoi nous avons déposé cette
pétition sur le site du sénat qui
propose des mesures élaborées à partir
des témoignages reçus on les a déjà un
petit peu évoqué je vais les détails et
un tout petit peu plus donc on demande
d'abord l'interdiction de la chasse le
mercredi et le dimanche le territoire
national sans possibilité aucune
dérogation on rappelle que selon le
dernier sondage ipsos datant de
septembre 2021 82% des français sont
favorables à cette mesure et que nos
voisins européens ont pour la plupart
déjà adopté au moins un jour
hebdomadaire sans chasse au vu des
nombreux accidents de chasseurs comme de
nos chasseurs il est évident que la
formation des chasseurs ainsi que les
règles de sécurité sont insuffisantes et
doivent être revus partager les espaces
naturels avec des hommes armés dans les
conditions actuelles est inenvisageable
nous demandons une distance de sécurité
autour des maisons des routes et des
chemins au moins égale la distance
maximale de porter des armes nous
demandons que le dernier soit renouvelée
chaque année avec un certificat
psychologique et médical à l'appui comme
cela est demandé pour n'importe quelle
licence sportive
il est par ailleurs inadmissible que
l'on continue à considérer de manière
aussi légères et laxiste l'acquisition
et la détention d'armé de catégorie c
les cales létale pardon jusqu'à trois
kilomètres qui sont bien plus puissantes
que celles utilisées par nos forces de
l'ordre ces armes se retrouvent
d'ailleurs très régulièrement dans des
cas d'homicides et de féminicide commis
hors actions de chasse et qui aurait pu
être évitée par exemple le 11 juin
dernier une mère de famille a été abattu
par arme de chasse par son ex-compagnon
chasseurs sur un parking public de
monéteau l'assassin était titulaire d'un
permis de chasse il était déjà connu de
la justice pour violences conjugales
combien de faits divers similaires
combien d'homicide et de fait ici tu
commis avec des armes de chasse par des
personnes qui les détenaient de manière
complètement légal étant donné la
facilité d'acquisition et de détention
d'armes en france via le permis de
chasser nous demandons un réel contrôle
et suivi de ses armes sur le territoire
national
les victimes de la chasse doivent
également pouvoir s'exprimer en toute
tranquillité sans subir de représailles
et sans craindre que leur plainte soit
classée sans suite comme cela arrive
trop régulièrement
d'autre part nous demandant des
sanctions pénales systématiques en
réponse à tout incident survenu lors
d'une action de chasse la possibilité du
retrait immédiat et définitif du permis
de chasse et l'interdiction définitive
de détenir une arme ou d'acquérir une
âme des dédommagements et intérêts
conséquents et des peines
d'emprisonnement stricte et terne nous
demandons enfin une reconnaissance
officielle et publique des victimes
directes et collatéral de la chasse par
l'état ainsi que la mise en place
systématique d'un soutien psychologique
et financier roanne quine le petit rat
orphelin de nos organes de 23 ans qui
était présent lors du drame n'a à ce
jour bénéficié d'aucun soutien
psychologique ni financier
un législateur qui prend le risque de
faire cohabiter 98% de la population
avec 2 % de chasseurs dont les balles
sont incontrôlables et létal jusqu'à 3
km et qui le sait est donc responsable
des accidents qui peuvent en découler
depuis maintenant un an nous avons
réussi à montrer que ces drames
n'étaient pas des cas exceptionnels ni
des accidents mais les conséquences d'un
défaut de la loi qui autorise
l'utilisation d'armes dans l'espace
public alors que leur portée et leur
trajectoire mais peuvent être contrôlés
par les chasseurs
en créant le collectif un jour un
chasseur nous n'imaginions pas être ici
aujourd'hui devant vous un an tout juste
après la mort de morgane nous
n'imaginions pas l'importance du besoin
de la population rurale de faire
entendre sa voix lorsque son opinion et
sa souffrance sont généralement
complètement et volontairement ignorée
lorsque l'on parle de ruralité
mais les événements dramatiques récents
exceptionnellement médiatisés ces
dernières semaines se répète
malheureusement chaque année dans
l'indifférence et ne sont qu'une infime
partie de ce que subissent
quotidiennement les habitants et usagers
de la nature en période de chasse s'il
était jusque là passée sous silence par
la presse nationale et par les
institutions nous sommes efforcés depuis
maintenant un an de porter la parole des
ruraux pour rendre d'ici ces violences
dramé abus et en démontrer les anges les
enjeux sociaux comme politique ce besoin
n'a jamais jusque là étaient prises en
compte ni par les autorités ni par les
institutions ni par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous sommes fiers de porter
cette parole même s'il faut bien
l'admettre il est triste que l'on doive
jouer ce rôle qui devrait être celui de
l'état mais nous continuerons de le
tenir aussi longtemps qu'en france les
automobilistes seront tués d'une balle
dans la tête au volant de leur voiture
tant que des promeneurs des cyclistes et
des gens dans leur jardin auront le
thorax perforé tant que des balles
traverseront des maisons atterriront
dans les chambres d'enfants tant que des
animaux de compagnie seront retrouvé
criblé de plombs tant que des violations
de propriété privée seront perpétré tant
que des gens seront menacés insultés ou
humiliés par des hommes armés tant que
nous renoncerons à aller nous promener
par peur d'être confondus avec des
sangliers
et pour finir on a une vidéo un extrait
de témoignages à vous montrer
je pense que vous pourrez peut-être nous
faire passer le petit film par par mail
je ferai suivre on vous le fera suivre
intéressant merci merci mesdames pour
votre témoignage et je vais laisser la
parole aux rapporteurs
merci beaucoup moins présente mes chers
collègues mesdames tout d'abord devrait
donc vous dire que nous avons entendu
l'émotion qu'elle à votre compte tenu
des circonstances
des accidents et de la proximité que
vous aviez avec une des victimes
si donc nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
et nombreux dans cette mission c'est
bien parce que nous prenons en compte
évidemment votre pétition et que nous
souhaitons apporter des réponses
ces réponses elles seront le fruit de
travail de réflexion d'audition de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
évidemment des chasseurs des non
chasseurs des utilisateurs d' espaces
comme ça a été dit et que les travaux de
notre mission feront l'objet évidemment
d'un regard attentif à tous les points
que vous avez évoquées notamment donc la
question de l'armement la question
évidemment de la prise en charge des
victimes et de l'ensemble de la chaîne
alors pour ma part il me revient de de
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions peut être un peu plus précise
pour faire en sorte que vous puissiez
apporter vous votre regard vos idées
aussi qui nous permettront de pouvoir
avancer dans notre réflexion de façon
objective et jeudi deux façons
très détaché le plus possible à la fois
de la partie et émotion mais aussi de la
partie
qui est lié à cette pratique
de la chasse et qui est une passion pour
pour certains
alors ma première question
elle concerne en fait un constat que je
souhaiterais donc partager avec vous
j'aimerais que vous apportiez ou encore
une fois votre vos commentaires en fait
si on regarde les chiffres de façon
brutale le nombre d'accidents de chasse
et est en forte baisse depuis 20 ans
lors de la moitié
en général plus importante encore
presque une division par 4 tous les
accidents mortels
néanmoins il semble qu'une fois sans
notre mission dispose de chiffres précis
à ce stade que le nombre d'incidents
c'est à dire l'impact de projectile sur
les habitations des véhicules sans
causer de blessures graves les avait été
évoquée serait donc lui en hausse est ce
que votre collectif a pu re a semblé
donc ces données et quels sont ils
alors moi je voudrais rebondir a pas de
ce que vous dites parce que c'est des
chiffres effectivement qui sont donnés
par loyauté
pardon
les chiffres que vous évoquez donc sont
des chiffres qui sont donnés par par le
fbi il ya un graphique donc très bien
fait avec le chef de 99 et le chiffre à
2020 et nous en fait on est un peu
énervé enfin agacé de voir que ce
graphique revient régulièrement parce
que en fait on prend un chiffre de 99
qui est le chiffre le plus élevé
d'accidents de chasse des 20 dernières
années il ya eu 39 morts en 99 on prend
celui de 2020 où il y en a eu le moins
on était en plein confinement en a eu
sept et il n'y a aucune
aucun calcul en fait aucune prise en
compte des chiffres intermédiaires sa
belle aux taux d'évolution en fait le
calcul on l'a fait enfin je peux vous
l'envoyez ciblées c'est très simple et
on prend un chiffre un autre on prend
pas en compte la moyenne du nombre de
de décès ou d'incident sur les autres
années ni non plus le nombre des
chasseurs en tête qui a fortement
diminué en 20 ans donc pour nous c'est
parce que déjà il est tronquée donc ça
c'est une première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que les incidents qui sont
recensés sont que les incidents en fait
qui ont fait l'objet d'une enquête de
gendarmerie et nous ce qu'on montre en
fait est ce que est ce qu on veut
montrer ce qu'on pense qu'on arrive à
montrer c'est qu'en fait c'est une
partie infime du nombre d'incidents
total donc ce chiffre il est pas du tout
représentatif pour nous en fait du
malade de la réalité d'accord mais ma
question c'était ça va est-ce que vous
disposer d'éléments dont vous me dites
oui vous vous disposez des
complémentaires donc que vous pouvez
ça c'est 20 par jour depuis un an il ya
eu un peu un trou cet été mais donc on
n'a pas compté boutabout parce que voilà
mais c'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui sur
les plateformes mail instagram twitter
des témoignages mais pas forcément des
collectes de chiffres avec ça c'est
quelque chose qui doit être parce que
nous on a ces témoignages donc on a les
gens qui nous envoie tous les voilà tu
ces choses là nous elle est abonnée de
collectif
non on ne peut pas donner un état
chiffré ces affaires est en fait en tout
cas ce qu'on peut vous dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces témoignages ces vingt
par jour
je me permets de poursuivre les
questions je serai bien sûr la parole à
mes collègues donc qu'ils en auront j'en
suis convaincu vous avez évoqué des
exemples étrangers à savoir ce qui se
passait à l'étranger sur le sujet est-ce
que vous disposez des exemples à suivre
ou d'idées qui vous aurez donc justement
interpellés je vous avez des contacts
avec un certain pays vous nous indiquez
les pays les plus pertinents en la
matière et nous dira si effectivement
vous avez fait des comparaisons par
rapport au nombre d'accidents dans ces
pays
alors non on n'a pas on n'a pas fait de
comparaison non et en fait ces chiffres
ils viennent de vue note du sénat je
note du sénat wii dont je parle de
huy a mené une enquête latine en europe
sur les
donc oui j'ai parlé rente est exactement
quel pays fait appel de leurs jours dans
quel pays
hormis ceux qui on a présenté dans la
paix des pétitions donc on a est
brouillé les voilà les pays dans la
pétition qu on a évoqué c'est ce dont on
a enfin voilà dont on sait enfin basé
sur les données et les notes qui avait
été faite par le sauna il ya quelques
années donc voilà on s'est basé sur ça
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de contacts à
l'étranger mais voilà on sait enfin ce
que je sais c'est que au royaume uni par
exemple ça n'existe pas y a pas autant
de morts en tout cas il n'y a pas autant
de morts en pologne etc si les deux
seules choses
allaient donc une corrélation entre
justement le fait qu'ils aient donc
moins deux morts au royaume uni par
exemple et des pratiques ou des règles
qui seraient différentes des règles
couple existe en france
donc vous n'avez pas ces éléments
merci
vous avez évoqué les conditions
d'obtention de validation du permis de
chasse donc la matière quelles sont vos
propositions
pour pouvoir modifier et justement
garantir
plus de sécurité
est-ce que vous avez des propositions
par exemple l'âge aujourd'hui le père
michel se passe à 16 ans à partir de 15
ans on peut aller chasser en étant
accompagnés donc en fait on peut chasser
avant d'avoir son permis de voiture
avant d'aller voter c'est donc pour nous
là j'étais un des premiers éléments du
permis après en terme de des preuves
donc là les as tu peux dire mais en fait
il ya une épreuve pratique et théorique
et il n'y a pas de stade ias qui pour
une moyenne des deux sur les épreuves il
faut pas voilà si on rate l'une des deux
c'est pas grave si la moyenne correspond
peut quand même avoir le permis donc
nous on aimerait par exemple que
si l'épreuve pratique est ratée en fait
ça empêche d'avoir le permis de chasser
par exemple est-ce que donc par rapport
à l'âge je ne peux même un complément
est-ce que vous avez donc pu vérifier
que il ya plus d'accidents jetons j'ai
des jeunes chasseurs que les chasseurs
plus expérimentés
est-ce que vous avez des notions de ça
ce sont des données d'ailleurs à ce
point là jamais fin c'est là vous avez
parlé des données de l'eau avait baissé
quelque chose d'aussi qu'on aimerait
voir c'est une transparence de ces
données c'est à dire que effectivement
on quand on regarde ces données on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya derrière la
définition d'incidents et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est important à savoir
en fait quand on peut il faut vraiment
définir les termes et donc pour cette
question de donner aussi c'est ça il
faudrait des chiffres pour pouvoir
affirmer ça parce que effectivement nous
c'est ce qu'on entend ça que ça soit
voilà les règles de sécurité ont changé
ce sont les chasseurs aulas qui ont le
permis depuis longtemps qui commettent
des
voiles à des tirs mortels des choses
comme ça bon morgan keane il a été
touché par un chasseur de 32 ans qui
venait d'avoir son permis six mois avant
la question de l'interdiction d'achat ce
mercredi et dimanche en quoi cela
garantirait justement la sécurité
c'est vrai qu'on peut aller se promener
tranquillement le dimanche c'est la
retirer ça veut dire qu'on interdit tous
les autres jours aussi
présent plein de personnes ne vont pas
se promener en période de chasse et
s'interdisent d'aller sortir quand voilà
quand il risque de se prendre donc vous
vous êtes plutôt sur une notion de
partage de l'espace peut pas forcément
sur un jour donné ou sur un jour donné
mais qui n'est pas forcément le mercredi
et le dimanche ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que le mercredi à dimanche ne
sont pas forcément les éléments
déterminants dans votre proposition
pardon
au minimum le dimanche un cessez de la
ccan tellement logique en fait on est
environ 15 millions selon les variantes
selon les la valeur de nos calculs mais
au minimum en qualité 15 millions de
ruraux ya environ un million de
chasseurs donc voilà c'est 15 millions à
28 millions selon les données de l'insee
de la datar sur la définition les
périmètres que l'on prend pour désigner
les ruraux où les campagnes les zonages
à la veille de ce groupe ares départ
avec la soustraction en fait ça fait au
moins de 14 millions d'euros non
chasseurs qui peuvent pas aller se
promener la moitié de l'année en fait ça
c'est pas c'est pas normal je voudrais
pas 14 millions de gens qui vont se
promener tous les dimanches mais mais
c'est pas le souvenir en fait il ya cet
état docteur c'est pas le sujet ce que
je voulais dire par là c'est que quelque
part georges en tant qu' l'importance et
de partage en fait de l'espace avec une
sécurisation qui est donné aux uns et
aux autres en fonction de leur
utilisation et leur pratique
vous avez parlé aussi d'un point qui est
donc la création d'une distance de
sécurité autour des habitations
donc aujourd'hui donc
cette notion n'existe pas
selon vous quelle serait la bonne
distance
j'ai tient pas bien ce micro aux
fonctions des armes
on va avoir des déportés qui sont très
différentes donc est-ce que donc ce
serait donc quelque chose de
d'arbitraire ou est-ce que donc
justement il faudrait peut-être intégrer
la notion du type d'armes utilisé pour
justement définir c'est cette distance
aujourd'hui on a des armes qui tire qui
sont les tel jusqu'à trois kilomètres
qui traverse entièrement des maisons des
baies vitrées des murs donc en fait
si ces armes sont utilisées pour être
sûr que enfin à trois kilomètres en fait
elle ne peut rien touché on a des fins
il ya eu là c'est en novembre dernier
une maison de retraite qui a été enfin
en mayenne à mayenne kate la région une
balle qui avait été tiré à 1,2 km donc
effectivement en fait le fait d'avoir
des armes de telle portée devrait
obliger en fait d'être sûr qu'il ya un
périmètre de sécurité où cette baleine
si elle n'attirait n'a pas d'obstacle il
faut qu'elle ne touche en fait ni
personne n'est ni aucun voilà bâtiment
ou quoi que ce soit ou alors on réduit
la portée des jardins oui mais c'est
quand même c'est quand même assez
étonnant qu'une arme peut aller jusqu'à
du capital jusqu'à deux kilomètres qu'on
utilise dans la nature dans l'espace
public
des armes qui ont une portée de 2 km 1
ou 3 mai de
ses fans aussi a priori on va pas tirer
sangliers qui à deux kilomètres de nous
donc déjà juste le fait qu'on peut
utiliser ses armes dans la nature c'est
complètement absurde après voilà à
partir de là on peut les utiliser taxi
man il faudrait adapter l'histoire de
sécurité à la portée des hommes
d'accord
je pense qu'il est dûment faut avoir une
mesure oui regard pragmatique sur le
site sur le sujet ce n'est pas
exactement une question de distance mais
plus
d'intérêt par rapport à l'armée elle
même
dans votre pétition vous vous déploré
l'absence d'exhaustivité du fichier
national des personnes interdites
d'acquisition et de détention d'armes
sur ce point
le projet de loi relatif à la
responsabilité pénale à la sécurité
intérieure qui devrait entrer en vigueur
au 1er janvier 2022 apporte des
modifications de nature à garantir à ce
fichier une plus grande effectivité pas
réellement vous demander un contrôle un
suivi plus strict des armes de chasse
quelles sont vos propositions en la
matière
sur le contrôle
ben en fait non c'est pas quelqu'un
l'alsace qu'il faut mettre en place du
coup pour le suivre
non on sait ce dont on s'est rendu
compte c'est que c'est très affligée
sait pas où la connexion se fait pas en
fait mais par exemple dans les cas qu'on
consiste dans la pétition des gens qui
ont été condamnés pour violences
conjugales ou qui ont eu voilà c'est le
cas par exemple du d'un père qui a tué
sa fille récemment avec son fusil de
chasse qui avait enfin cette fille avec
déjà porté plainte contre l'iran toi il
y avait eu une dénonciation de violence
et enfin comment ces gens là encore des
armes chez eux en fait il ya un problème
le nom sait pas où est le problème qui
n'a pas retiré larmes est ce que c'est
voilà que la plaine qui a pas été au bon
endroit si le gendarme ne la partageons
sais pas mais en tout cas toujours actif
évidemment il ya un souci quelque part
donc après voilà
vous fait entrer deux
en la matière donc vous avez des
exemples de ce type l'ag qu'ils
pourraient donc vous être utile sur
votre plateforme
témoignages ou des idées oui
régulièrement d'ailleurs on a un au
témoignage vidéo effectivement d'un cas
qui s'était passé dans le lot où une
femme avait donc porté plainte pour
violences conjugales par son mari
chasseurs il y avait une restriction de
périmètre elle est morte et oui oui
césar n'avait pas été retiré la question
se pose qui doit retirer les armes en
fait est ce que c'est la gendarmerie est
ce que c'est les fédérations de chasse
est ce que c'est la préfecture on ne
sait pas mais en tout cas on a plusieurs
témoignages qui font état de ce genre de
là on parle de féminicide mais aussi d'
homicide vous vous considérez que sur ce
point là donc il ya quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas alors même que donc
finalement de tous les éléments pour
pouvoir
le mettre en place oui quand les armes
sont détenus légalement on devrait
pouvoir connaître les comportements à
risque et les identifier sachant qu'il y
a pas de contrôle aujourd'hui
psychiatriques psychologiques pour
passer le permis de chasse et obtenir la
remet donc effectivement ça aussi c'est
quelque chose d'important à prendre en
compte en l'occurrence compte
effectivement je vous disais que j'avais
une modification donc aux législatives
qu'il faudra à vis de mon
challenge est donc vérifier pour
corriger cet effet donc que vous et vous
je suis désolé pourtant jeu j'essaye
d'être
ouais c'est vrai
alors question concernant les sanctions
pénales
vous dénoncez donc les refus de plainte
donc donc certaines situations où le
classement sans suite de ces plaintes
est-ce que là aussi vous avez des
exemples précis
concernant cesser ses dires
et en plus en plus ils s'arrêtent au
micro je suis désolé je sais pas
pourquoi
on me boycott
en la matière et la question est-ce que
vous pensez que il serait nécessaire de
sensibiliser
les forces de l'ordre sur ce sujet oui
complètement alors après on s'est posé
la question aussi d'avoir des référents
qui soit neutre et du coup qu'il fasse
pas partie du village en fête parce que
souvent c'est le problème c'est le
problème de la campagne est déjà en fait
qui témoigne c'est que tout le monde se
connaît tout le monde a un ami un
beau-frère voilà quelqu'un dans son
entourage qui chassent et il ya il ya un
vrai problème à s'exprimer et c'est une
réalité et il ya beaucoup de gens qui
nous font pas de représailles voilà qui
sont qui sont qui leur sont arrivés
après avoir essayé de porter plainte en
tout cas après avoir dénoncé un
comportement il ya souvent une proximité
on a eu un témoignage par exemple d'un
cas où le
où un jeune homme en fait avait eu une
altercation avec des chasseurs et la
gendarmerie avait donné le numéro de
portable de ce personnes à partir sa
plaque d'immatriculation
voilà enfin cesser les choses graves
c'est très grave et en fait y'a on
retrouve très régulièrement ça dans les
dents les témoignages des liens entre
gendarmerie et chassa entre le maire et
les chasseurs est un vrai problème à ce
sujet là donc peut-être avoir des
référés en fait qu'ils se soient pas
qu'ils dressent pas forcément partie du
village et qu'ils soient les révérends
quoi mais quelqu'un qui ont pu
s'adresser en fait si on a un problème
est qu'ils puissent un référent
gendarmerie par exemple la page voit
donc
centralisé à la préfecture ou que je
veux qu'il y ait pas de lien avec le dit
l'argentin après ça c'est une idée comme
ça sachant que les gendarmes qui est qui
et qui use de ses dérives 20 sont dans
une situation qui est quand même assez à
se repprocher c'était vraiment posé
mais par contre l'euro fut de plainte ça
c'est très très quoi
il est plein de sang suite là vous nous
demandiez si on avait des exemples oui
on en a on en a 1 notamment c'était à
montpellier une belle qui dépeint dans
l'est dans le périurbain de montpellier
une balle qui a été retrouvé dans une
chambre d'enfant au bout de trois ans la
famille était sans nouvelles on a les
photos les articles avait lui-même un
reportage france 3 la plainte avait été
classée sans suite alors que le chasseur
avait été retrouvé suite à la balle
identifier et donc voilà ça c'est un
exemple qu'on a et on en a plusieurs en
sont
d'accord et donc on reviendra peut-être
sur les
informations dont vous disposez et qui
pourraient vous être utiles et que vous
pourriez de nous transmettre de façon
peut-être justement
classés en fonction de ces différents
cas vous avez évoqué aussi donc un point
important
qui est la prise en charge des victimes
ou des proches de victimes vous avez
cité l'exemple donc de votre amie
en la matière quelles seraient vos
demandes
concrètement donc on a dit un soutien
psychologique et financier non a été
choquée en fait de voir qu'on
considérait enfin la mort de norman en
fait c'était au même c'est la même chose
en fait que s'il avait était mort d'une
autre manière c'est c'est quelque chose
qui est super violent on se fait tirer
dessus dans son jardin star parfum c1
c'est une mort qu'on ne devrait pas
pouvoir accepter ni même envisagée en
fait dans notre société et le fait que
en personne soit allé lui demander s'il
a bien de quoi que ce soit ça pose
question quand même donc un soutien
psychologique et financier dans quelle
mesure je sais pas mais en tout cas il
faut il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose après après ce genre de choses il
ya beaucoup de gens ici que nous ont
écrit qu'ils nous ont dit bah voila moi
je continue à habiter dans le même
village que le chasseur qui a tué mon
mari ou le chasseur qui a tué mon père
qui a repris ses activités
professionnelles normalement et a
recommencé à chasser cinq ans ou dix ans
après parce que là en général ces dix
ans maximum interdiction de suspension
du permis de chasser après homicide oui
on trouve ici donc il ya un problème
quand même
dans la en fait le problème est dans la
considération de ces drames qui ont des
accidents est ce que pendant le
confinement par exemple ces petits les
lignes dérogation pour la chasse mais
c'était la seule activité donc si l'état
estime qu'il a une mission d'intérêt
public en fait il est responsable de ce
qui arrive pendant cette mission
d'intérêt public et donc il ya une
responsabilité à prendre par les
victimes en fait qu'ils sont qui résulte
en fait de cette mission
en l'occurrence sur le cas que vous
évoquez il ya une procédure en cours
oui elle est en cours donc globalement
cette procédure devrait donner lieu
justement a donc
des bandes sanctions et le groupe en
attendant il fait qu'on parle de
victimes qu'elle 6 à des proches
dans la période justement de cette cette
procédure
j'imagine mais en attendant voilà il est
tout ça les personnes
oui je disais que enfin on parle de on
parle d'un a fait qu'ils traversent des
corps et des victimes qui sont
présentent souvent des proches la
famille des amis on parle de ça
effectivement le procès il a lieu en
2022 on ne sait pas ce qui aura combien
de temps ça va durer combien ça va être
mis en place mais en fait c'est
maintenant qu'il faut prendre en charge
c'est le jour même il faut qu'on en
charge
notamment des psychologies que je je je
je vous l'accordé je l'entends
mes chers collègues est ce que quelqu'un
des questions complémentaires oui
dominic champagne
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
rapporteur mesdames en tout cas vraiment
voilà on est touché par par votre
témoignage par bien évidemment cette
initiative et on part donc on partage
effectivement l'émotion qui est qui est
la vôtre moi je voudrais savoir sur les
accidents de chasse récent total et des
plus récents est ce que vous avez pu
analyser quelles ont été les causes de
ces accidents est-ce que c'est plutôt de
mauvaise manipulation à ce que ce sont
plutôt des imprudences de la part des
chasseurs alors je rate l'une d'entre
vous a dit qu' il y avait quelqu'un qui
la personne qui avait tué avait son
permis de chasse depuis très peu de
temps est ce que vous avez pu faire une
analyse vous remontez dans autant faire
se peut les causes et est ce que ces
causes elles sont très diverses ou
est-ce qu'elle elle se concentre autour
de certains certains actes enfin en tout
cas donc ça c'est ma première question
est donc est ce que là aussi sur les
causes est-ce que ça se passe plutôt
quand il ya de grandes battues est-ce
que c'est plutôt lorsque li h à cet
individu elle est ce que quand il yal de
trois personnes enfin voilà est-ce que
vous avez des éléments qui permettent
autant que faire se peut la voir un peu
plus de deux
éléments concernant ces différents
accidents de chasse et puis une autre
question vous dans votre pétition vous
dit qu'il faudrait interdire la chasse
certains jours les mercredis et dès
dimanche est ce que pour vous ça
pourrait être entendent abl que de dire
que plutôt que d'interdire la chasse
certains jours est ce que par exemple
d'isoler de sécuriser certaines zones en
sanctuarisant des endroits qui sont
interdits à la chasse parce que ce sont
des endroits identifiés comme étant des
circuits de randonnées ou de grande
randonnée parmi les plus fréquentés est
ce que ça vous paraît aussi une une
possibilité une éventualité qui pourrait
améliorer les choses et voir pour même
sur des lieux où il y a des par exemple
débattu et on sait qu'il ya souvent
aujourd'hui parce que les sangliers je
ne prends que cet exemple la prospère
débattu importante de sanglier et y
compris aux frontières des villes pas
uniquement dans les zones les plus
rurales et les pelures trancher est-ce
que mieux indiquée mieux sécuriser ces
zones boisées dans lesquelles les
battues ont lieu afin que les
randonneurs dont bien même il décide où
il gérait dans ces lieux soient quand
même autant faire se peut les mieux
informés possible pour prendre le moins
de risques possibles est-ce que là
dessus vous avez des éléments à nous
apporter merci
alors pour la première question
concernant les causes est ce que c'est
lié à une imprudence et c'est alors pour
les cas mortels en fait c'est quelque
chose qu'on aimerait savoir sur la
transparence des données qui sont donnés
par le fbi parce que nous on peut enfin
regarder des choses on va à lire des
choses dans la presse en fait mais pour
donner des fins des chiffres et des
analyses ça c'est un travail qui doit
être fait avec ces données sous les yeux
il y a quelque chose quand même qu'il
faut préciser c'est que quand on a un
président représentant des chasseurs
nationale willy schraen qui dit que même
si les règles de sécurité étaient
respectées
il ya en fait c'est un accident donc la
possibilité que même si ces règles
étaient respectées et que le chasseur
n'avait pas été imprudent ces réactions
c'est enfin voilà il ya un drame qui se
produit ça montre bien qu'en fait ces
règles elles sont inopérantes
voilà sur le premier point le second
point ce qu'on voit en fait dans le cas
d'un site de drame donc de tir mortel
souvent effectivement ça se passe lors
de battues parce que les armes en fait
elles sont extrêmement puissante et elle
sont mortelles après il ya beaucoup
d'incidents qui se passe donc avec des
ricochets aidé de la présente un des
explosions de plomb etc et
enfin ça n'empêche pas que si la
personne ne meurt pas en fait elle est
quand même blessé
voilà
concernant l'interdiction de la chasse
par rapport à certaines zones pour nous
enfin c'est quelque chose qui serait
absolument insuffisant il n'y a pas de
mur dans les forêts aujourd'hui si on a
des armes qui tire jusqu'à 3 km
ça paraît enfin voilà n'y a pas de mur
dans les forêts pour arrêter ces belles
là est le problème en fait tu restes
toujours que la portée des armes est
trop dangereuse et aujourd'hui on voit
bien quand on se promène sur des
sentiers de randonnée on peut se situer
voilà les figurants revel 2015 samuel
rinaudo il était sur un sentier de
randonnée de grande randonnée en isère
quand on voit viarhôna il ya une
cycliste qui s'est pris du plomb dans la
cheville et en faisant du vélo moi j'ai
aussi une autre question pour une balle
qui touche quelqu'un dans sa voiture à
la tête qui meurt et ceara qui traverse
une voiture et qui tue sept personnes
combien de balle traverse nos routes et
nous et nos chemins et qui ne touchent
aucun obstacle ça c'est ma question que
je pose
je crois que paul haggis allemand avait
une question puis marie mercier
merci
merci à vous pour ces témoignages on a
beau être au courant des drames il ya la
chasse c'était
pour venir en touchant
merci pour cela merci pour votre travail
aussi de compilation parce que
effectivement il ya plein de choses qui
que l'on ne connaît pas parce que l'on
ne trouve que ce que l'on cherche et on
voit que par votre cité par votre
association vous avez déjà eu un écho de
nombreux témoignages que l'on n'aurait
pas eu autrement donc c'est pour dire
que j'ai parlé de la partie immergée de
l'iceberg je pense que on est
complètement là
je me poserai une question concernant le
dimanche et le mercredi sans chasse
je sais que vous n'avez pas pris ces
jours là où aja au hasard c'est une
question sans doute de fréquentation
certainement est ce que pour vous c'est
un
ce suffisant c'est un minimum
voilà où est ce que vous voudriez aller
exactement est ce que vous y avez
réfléchi plus que ça j'aimerais bien
savoir si quels sont aujourd'hui vos
relations avec le monde de la chasse
avec les habitants de votre terroir
est ce que il vient il y a une vraie
écoute est ce que vous faites l'objet
d'intimidations voilà des choses de ce
goût là
et puis autre question on sait que les
chasseurs et bien fondées battu parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a une prolifération
terrible du grand gibier et en
particulier des sangliers avec lui d'une
multiplication par dix dans de nombreux
départements du nombre de bêtes abattues
comment voyez-vous c'est cette
régulation du grand gibier est-ce que
vous avez des pistes de réflexion sur ce
sujet merci
d'accord alors pour répondre à la
première question sur les jours sans les
jours un chat ce pardon le dit marc
jennar produit effectivement c'est un
minimum on pense que deux jours par
semaine bon c'est bien mais
effectivement c'est pas il n'y a pas de
on n'a pas de restriction là dessus si
ça peut être plus dans vieux aussi si ça
peut être effectivement pendant les
vacances scolaires et tout le week-end
on va pas être déçu mais le dimanche
c'est le dimanche et mercredi pour nous
c'est essentiel
voilà donc après où est-ce qu'on est ce
qu on veut aller nous on a cinq mesures
qui sont phare et qui on pense en tout
cas permettront vraiment de faire
changer les choses est de diminuer le
nombre d'accidents pendant le réduire à
zéro et donc voilà on a déjà commencé
par là par rapport à nos rapports avec
avec le monde de la chasse on a eu des
contacts on a eu des échanges avec des
chasseurs on est régulièrement insulter
sur les réseaux sociaux mais bon après
c'est un reste c'est
à peu près on s'y attendait plus ou
moins donc donc voilà
oui voilà donc c'est pas ces paroles
assez normal aux inerties et les
intimidations enfin on a eu nous on
n'habite plus dans le lot actuellement
on a eu des échos par contre de gens qui
donc d'une de la soeur de millas très
concrètement qui était qui a été voilà
qui a été interpellé par une femme de
chasseurs qui l'a dit donc dans le
village à côté de cages à gaillac qui
lui a dit vas
attention ça serait dommage que y est
notre accident c'était une mise en garde
sous la forme d'une menace donc ça
arrive et effectivement le les retours
qu'on a en tout cas de la part des
chasseurs c'est c'est que de toute façon
nos mesures elles sont stupides et
qu'elles sont inapplicables voilà il n'y
a pas de débat possible
concernant les battues au grand gibier
on a un problème en fait par rapport à
ça c'est que si on considère qu' on est
obligé de réguler la population de
sangliers ça veut dire que c'est quelque
chose qui doit être mise en place par
l'état et contrôlée par l'état pour nous
on peut pas donner ce pouvoir là à des
gens qui sont pas formés pour ça et qui
savent pas en fait qu'ils sont pas
formés non plus ni à la biodiversité ni
au maniement correcte des armes est en
fête qui leur donne en fait ce droit là
on leur donne le pouvoir de dire ben moi
je suis plus j'estime que vous les
promeneurs les cyclistes les randonneurs
à être là parce que je suis investie
d'une mission d'intérêt général à partir
du moment où l'état le demande pour nous
il faut que ce soit régulée d'une autre
manière en fait faut que ce soit de
professionnaliser
si
d'après monsieur mérillou merci madame
la présidente sera porteur mais mes
chers collègues je voudrais déjà vous
vous remercier les dames pour avoir
lancé cette pétition et on on comprends
la souffrance qui peut être la vôtre et
ce besoin que vous avez surtout d'éviter
que ça se reproduise si je comprends
bien
in fine et vos propos donc bien axé sur
la prévention je voudrais faire trois
remarques la loi de juillet 2020 en fait
renforcer les dispositifs de
confiscation des armes c'était la loi
qui est arrivé après le grenelle sur les
violences conjugales et il y avait des
dispositions pour pour renforcer la
confiscation justement quand il y avait
des antécédents de violence conjugale
donc je pense que peut-être vous avez eu
connaissance de cela ensuite en ce qui
concerne ce qu'on peut appeler les
victimes témoins s'étaient aussi dans
cette loi ou un enfant qui voit là sa
maman subir des violences on considère
que en tant que témoin il est victime
donc je partage complètement l'idée de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
préconisations pour les témoins dans le
cas d'accident aussi violent et aussi
choquant que celui là pour qu'il ya un
accompagnement sérieux qui doit
effectivement être mis en place très
rapidement sur le plan psychologique et
les accompagnement psychologique ça
coûte cher donc effectivement il
faudrait qu'il y ait des dispositions
qu'ils soient prévus pour cela ensuite
je voulais savoir si vous aviez
consulter ses santé publique france qui
publie des opuscules y en a un qui
s'appelle décès traumatique en pratique
sportive puisque la chasse est
considérée comme une pratique sportive
donc les les éléments que j'ai pu
construite consultés on voyait
qu'effectivement il des sports dangereux
il ya des morts quand on fait de la
plongée quand on fait de lui il aime
quand on fait du ski mais moi c'est de
la mort concerne l'usagé lui même et ne
concerne pas sauf de rares cas les
spectateurs en bord de piste ou un
malheureux qu'ils traversent à ce moment
là et donc la suède avait fait des
préconisations qui s'était rendu compte
que les accidents de chasse et est
beaucoup liée à l'erreur humaine mais
les préconisations qu'ils avaient qu'ils
avaient fait en fait avait amené
vraiment une grosse diminution du nombre
d'accidents est ce que vous avez eu
connaissance de cela
moi j'ai pas eu connaissance de cela et
la lampre union donc nous n'avons pas eu
connaissance
merci
steam et rio oui moi je suis étonné de
la masse d'informations que vous avez pu
recueillir avec une association je
suppose qu'ils aient qui est
relativement jeune puisqu'elle a été
créée à partir voilà et donc je voulais
savoir si si vous avez d'autres
associations qui me paraît légitime et
qui vous aide dans la compilation de
cette masse de documents parce que si
vous à tous les deux et peut-être
quelques amis vous avez pu recueillir
cette masse de documents je suppose que
l'office français de la biodiversité
sera en capacité de nous donner aussi un
tas d'éléments et moi je suis très
preneur là dessus
sur la régulation et c'est aussi une
question composera l'office la
biodiversité on régule un excès de
population et on ne régule en tuant des
animaux ski
la méthode probablement la plus simple
mais il ya peut-être d'autres méthodes
biologique pour réguler des animaux que
d'en lâcher ou ou d'avoir des quantité
d'animaux qu'il faut ensuite réguler
donc
je suis pas sûr que vous soyez poser ces
questions là mais je crois qu'il faudra
aussi qu'on les voit avec l'office de la
biodiversité qu'on a mais mais sur
comment vous vous organiser ça c'est à
titre de curiosité parce que vous y
consacrez probablement énormément de
temps si j'ai bien compris oui alors on
n'est pas aidé par d'autre part n'est
pas aidé par d'autres nations et
soutenue par des assauts avec à psion
déjà demandé des conseils plus de
stratégie ou comme ça mais par contre
pour la compilation des informations non
on est on est quatre actuellement dans
le collectif et on a on a tout fait tout
seul après on a beaucoup d'abonnés du
coup qui nous relève voilà des qui dès
qu'ils ont échos d'un accident d'un
incident c'est voilà on est on a des
gens on va dire qu'ils nous aident par
la force des choses parce qu'ils ont
envie de de témoigner de ce qui se passe
à côté de chez eux et c'est ce qui s'est
passé mais mais non là c'est clairement
oui on y passe beaucoup de temps et on
travaille tout à côté donc je pense
élections que le fdf serait en mesure de
donner des données précises
et pour ce qui concerne la régulation
alors il ya des c'est parce que je crois
que ça l'a récemment il y a eu un test
qui a été fait vers barcelone avec la
stérilisation des sangliers donc il ya
d'autres choses qui sont faites au
niveau européen et on peut regarder mais
effectivement cette question de
latéralisation je crois qu'il ya eu un
test assez récents qui était plutôt
positif donc voilà il ya des exemples à
prendre dans nos voisins européens ça
c'est sûr c'est des choses qui sont
sûrement plus coûteuse et qui sont
compliqués à mettre en place il faut
faire super attention avec ces sujets
mais c'est pas possible ça se fait si on
a envie de s'en donner les moyens à
prendre un exemple aussi de genève du
canton de genève où la chasse est
interdite depuis longtemps maintenant
c'est plus exactement quelle année mais
en tout cas je pense avant les années 80
et
et en fait à la can interdite par
rapport à la sécurité est depuis la
régulation des sangliers se fait par des
professionnels
voilà de la nuit il ya des points on les
tue quand même mais il ya des points
d'agrainage qui sont précis qui sont
connus il ya un calcul et une prise en
compte exact en fait du nombre d'animaux
qu'il faut qu'il faut tuer et ensuite
voilà il ya des gens m'ont aidée par
l'état qui vont et qui est écriture
latent de sangliers la nuit il ya aucun
risque pour la population humaine et
caméra d'or voilà depuis un mirador est
pas et on sait maintenant combien
d'espèces sans enfin combien de
d'animaux on doivent être régulés et
c'est donc ça existe des solutions il y
en a il faut il faut juste les chercher
et trouver laquelle est la plus
applicable et la moins coûteuse peut
être coûteuse de manière immédiate mais
je peux voir aussi sur le long terme
tracks maintenant ville
merci présidente et merci pour votre
exposé moi je voudrais revenir peut-être
sur vous avez évoqué le évidemment le
partage la nécessité de partage de
l'espace
et notamment au travers l'interdiction
souhaitable selon vous le de la chasse
dans un certain nombre d' espace le
mercredi et le dimanche
et je voudrais peut-être vous vous
alliez plus loin sur ce oui pardon vous
ne devez retirer le masque vous alliez
plus loin sur ce sur ce sujet est-ce
qu'on est ce que on peut entrevoir
peut-être une
une capacité à faire savoir à mieux
informer à mieux organiser aussi la
chasse sur les territoires pour faire en
sorte parce que il faut bien le dire ce
qui est la réalité de terrain sait que
c'est que dans une dans une journée de
chasse dans un massif qui peut
comprendre plusieurs centaines
d'hectares il n'y a qu'une une infime
partie qui est chassé donc
il a peut être un sujet aussi de de
meilleures informations de meilleure
déclaration
antérieure à la
dent par anticipation pour que les
riverains les usagers puissent aussi
davantage
utilisé des espaces restants et se
protéger enfin éviter des espaces
chasser alors comme l'a dit mina tout à
l'heure déjà effectivement y'a pas de
murs dans les forêts ou dans les massifs
montagneux donc isolé la chasse à une
partie du massif d'un père naturel etc
ce serait pas suffisant dans la mesure
où les armes ont des portées de plus de
2 km et par ailleurs c'est encore une
fois aux promeneurs de s'adapter donc à
une majorité de bureaux à s'adapter à
une minorité de gens dont qui sont armés
camp nou a priori quand je découvris
rocard je vais me promener je risque de
tuer personne donc ok on pourrait avoir
voilà c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
être complémentaires par exemple le
ballet jour du cou ou la chasse n'est
pas interdite ça pourrait quelque chose
qui doit rentrer en compte aussi dans
des réseaux sécurité plus strictes et
dans des mesures à prendre en compte
mais ça sera dans tous les cas pas
suffisant
alors c'est sûr qu'il ya quelque chose à
faire en termes d'information ça c'est
une évidence parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas enfin les habitantes des dix
villages ne savent pas en fait quand une
battue sur quel thème métral ces temps
où est ce qu'ils peuvent se ramener une
battue ces mobiles aussi ça se déplace
donc c'est ça aussi à prendre en compte
et il n'y a pas de système
uniformisé homogène pour accéder à ces
données c'est très très compliqué parce
que ben voilà c'est selon toutes les
communes les départements et c'est donc
ça effectivement il ya un manque et il
faudrait qu'ils aient ça
après ça n'empêche pas de voile à de
tomber nez à nez avec un chasseur qui
voit là à l'affût ou des choses comme ça
donc il ya aussi un problème de sécurité
qui dépasse enfin voilà sept
cette information
autre question
non pas de regret si madame la
présidente
tout à fait
merci mademoiselle pour c'est pour ces
témoignages qui sont évidemment très
important et qui ont prévalu à la
création évidemment de cette mission
d'information
on n'a pas parlé ou alors j'étais
inattentive du problème de l'alcool est
ce que vous avez dans vos témoignages
beaucoup de choses qui pourraient être
liés ou alors je sais bien vous n'avez
pas toutes les informations parce qu'en
fait vous avez pas les enquêtes ou ou
même c'est même pas recensé d'après ce
que vous nous dites mais est-ce que vous
avez quand même quelque part voilà c'est
tout à fait politiquement incorrect que
je veux dire mais je le dis quand même
voilà est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose là
dessus un point là-dessus qui est que
vous avez taupe et dans vos témoignages
alors déjà on a été choqué d'apprendre
que l'alcool à la chasse c'est pas
interdit il n'y a pas de loi qui
interdit de chasser en ayant consommé de
l'alcool et dans les témoignages ça
revient quand même assez régulièrement
des gens qui témoignent voilà deux repas
arrosé entre chasseurs et des gens qui
vont chasser ensuite ben voilà c'est
encore une fois normalement quand il ya
un accident et que le taux d'alcoolémie
positif c'est une coin circonstances
aggravantes et il doit y avoir une
sanction pénale plus plus importante
mais voilà après dans les témoignages
qu'on ressasse elle reviendrait très
souvent aussi oui voilà rien n'empêche
d'aller à la chasse en ayant bu alors
qu'on ne peut pas conduire voilà il ya
un taux minimal
et est donc oui on a des exemples de
voilà c'est plutôt ça sera plutôt des
témoignages qu'on a ou il ya des
altercations entre des promeneurs et des
chasseurs ou alors sur la route des
accidents de voiture ou des choses comme
ça
ça sera peut-être
pas d'autres questions si une dernière
monsieur seulement merci la présidente
c'est juste pour rebondir je trouve ça
intéressant d'avoir cette cette notion
d'alcoolémie
peut-être que je pense qu'on manque
cruellement de statistiques surtout ces
problématiques de chasse et on voit bien
que sans vouloir voir un côté péjoratif
on reste dans l'amateurisme et on est
des gens qui collectent et on a très peu
de données et même dans l'accidentologie
est ce qu'il y en a plus l'après midi
que le matin ça serait des choses à
l'inter intéressante à savoir parce que
ce qu'il faudrait pas interdire la
chasse l'après midi parce que
effectivement il ya des des effets
collatéraux donc je ne sais pas comment
poids compilé nous est ce qu'on peut
trouver d'autres informations mais après
avec l'eau est descendu je pense que
c'est des des données très importantes
pour essayer de cerner au mieux le sujet
ce qui pourrait limiter tout à fait je
suis entièrement d'accord et c'est sur
ça que aussi que je voulais conclure
avant de vous remercier pour cette
audition et vous dire que le sujet vous
l'avez vu au vu des questions que l'on a
que l'on vous a posé et encore on ne
peut pas rester non plus des heures à
vous retenir mais c'est un sujet très
vaste et très complexe avec des
difficultés sur la réalité des chiffres
entre les chiffres officiels et puis le
chiffre noir et vous vous avez témoigné
sur le nombre
tous au ccc nombreux témoignages que
vous avez sur votre site on est sûr sur
cette difficulté d'appréhension du
phénomène réellement d'aidé de
l'accidentologie sur la nature aussi sur
les causes et les contextes et le
contexte aussi de ces accidents non ça
je crois qu'il va falloir qu'on le
creuse et on verra avec les services de
l'état et on va auditionner près de près
de 40 auditions pendant six mois donc on
aura je pense de quoi faire le tour de
la question est en tout cas n'hésitez
pas si vous avez aussi des compléments à
rajouter vous n'hésitez pas
nous en faire part par mail
prendre en compte et merci en tout cas
pour votre témoignage